what i want to talk about first though
is
the idea that bitcoin is the only crypto
that matters and we have some new stats
that have come out recently that proves
this the point that we've been talking
about for a long time now that it's
bitcoin and then it's everything else so
bitcoin as a the market share dominance
has risen to levels uh over the last few
months that we hadn't previously seen
right since since you know years ago uh
so if you look at the yellow number
there
those are altcoins versus bitcoin so
it's the highest that we have seen since
october now it's rising again and i
think we know generally why this is
right in bull markets the uh amount of
capital that gets allocated towards
secondary coins or all coins uh or [ __ ]
coins depending on how you want to talk
about it
increases right people are looking for
longer tail assets that have a higher
degree of volatility and
can increase in price faster than
bitcoin what happens in bear markets is
the exact opposite right so we're seeing
this now start to play out where prices
have collapsed uh specifically tara
which is marketed there which is marked
on the chart there and bitcoin's market
share starts to climb again so
of all the market cap it looks like alt
season is uh ending and bitcoin is
climbing now it looks like over close to
45 of the total market cap so we have a
quote here from julio moreno a senior
analyst at crypto quant so typically
when there's a correction in crypto
markets altcoins underperform bitcoin as
they are perceived as higher risk coins
than bitcoin again i don't think this is
anything groundbreaking necessarily i
assume most people probably knew this by
now that when we move into bull markets
more of that capital gets allocated to
longer tail assets because of the degree
that they can appreciate versus bitcoin
as a singular asset and the largest
market cap up those assets so we have
another chart here that shows bitcoin's
correlation with the s p 500 which is
just off record highs so not only is it
becoming more of a market dominant force
within crypto in general but it's now
extremely correlated over the last few
months at least with the s p 500 so
these numbers you know over that we we
have uh about two years marked on the
chart here
have ranged anywhere from uh
point one zero percent uh to almost uh
point eight here now we're up so we're
approaching those all-time highs again
where bitcoin is now moving in
lockstep with the s p 500 and broader
equities in general not just necessarily
the s p 500 but it's become a risk asset
where people as rates start to rise
again these assets are selling off just
like stocks and everything else so if we
look at bitcoin compared to some of
these stocks uh the people that have
been complaining for a long time that
allocating a large percentage of your
portfolio to bitcoin is crazy because of
its volatility have obviously been
proven wrong if you look at the chart
here
year-to-date declines in these assets
bitcoin is down 37 percent meta formerly
known as facebook is down 44
netflix getting crushed down 68 tesla
down 37
amazon massive business oh everyone just
allocate all your money to amazon down
34 this year shopify down 75
google down 25
right and the point isn't necessarily
that bitcoin is outperforming these or
doing better than these or people should
allocate their money to bitcoin versus
some of these assets it's the general
idea that all risk assets right now are
getting crushed to some degree and
they're being grouped together and
bitcoin is part of that so if you want
to uh criticize people for putting a
large amount of their money or capital
in bitcoin then the same should be said
for a stock like amazon or netflix or
google or tesla or shopify et cetera and
i think what we've seen now is a lot of
the ceos are the people the operators of
these businesses outside of bitcoin i'm
talking about all those large market cap
stocks that we just talked about
they're all now starting to come out and
publicly say hey look our stock is
really cheap we believe it's really
cheap we haven't seen these levels in a
long time and i know some of them are
even publicly allocating their own
personal capital now back into the
business so they're saying we're going
to go buy
10 million 100 million dollars in some
cases and even more of their own stock
because they think it's reached values
now that they didn't perceive would be
coming for a long period of time so
not necessarily surprising uh that
bitcoin has seen kind of this reversal
with rates rising and the fed doing what
it's doing
but i would say that you got to zoom out
a little bit you got to look at the
broader market and people that are
criticizing bitcoin for dropping and
doing these things not only are not
accounting for everything that's
happened over the last 10 years from a
from an appreciation standpoint but
they're not typically looking at the
broader market and what has happened
there what are your general thoughts jen
explained it perfectly i think in bear
markets you're going to see a lot of
money be allocated
to all coins um and specifically just
not bitcoin because you can see a higher
price appreciation in those smaller
denominations of dollar amounts right so
if a coin is a dollar it has probably a
greater chance of going to two dollars
and bitcoin does is doubling in price
just based off the market cap of the
asset itself and then when you look at
the correlation between the s p it's not
really surprising at all right when
people sell
stuff they sell everything across the
board they don't just like kind of
nitpick um and selling crypt over
selling one of these large uh cap tech
stocks is it's normal right um you would
think that people have already allocated
and i think the argument is that for
inflation how bitcoin is not the
inflation is people have already
allocated their money and that's what
they were doing in early 2021 they knew
inflation was going to come they knew
what the government did the government
didn't even realize that there was going
to be this levels of inflation but the
private market did and i think people
did move a lot of that capital over um
and we're going to see in this year
whether it holds the test of time or not
yeah i mean the government could have
called 100 people that are uh investors
and they probably would have got a
better answer than the ones that they
got internally regarding the uh
inflation that we saw here in the united
states but i also think it speaks to
bull and bear markets right people
forget that bitcoin as the dominant
asset it's volatile but it's much less
volatile than everything else in the
crypto market in general so when you
look at all the all coins that we spoke
about earlier or anything else that's
considered those long tail assets
they've declined tremendously compared
to bitcoin over the last you know four
or five months uh or at least year to
date because bitcoin has a superior
asset that has a larger market cap it's
much more stable in context of the
decline that we've seen in broader
markets right stock market uh or
anything else so i think that it goes
both ways in the bull market sure there
may be some all coins that can
outperform but if you stick in those too
long we've seen it now where uh it's
much less safe to a degree now some of
those coins are down 90 95 99 in all in
in some cases uh and people have gotten
their financial situation ruined because
they've been playing around in these
situations that can drop a drop of a hat
right literally you can lose your money
based on trying to chase too many
profits in a bull market and it can
change we all see it now where it's
happened over a few months but at the
same time like that's kind of quick in
the in the grand scheme of things right
if you're looking at an ass and you're
expecting to go up
and you're emotionally attached to it
these all coins and people are rallied
around them and trying to get the price
to increase that's not necessarily a
game that i personally want to be
playing or i i think you should be
playing uh so bitcoin may be down but i
guess the broader point is a lot of
other assets that people group together
with bitcoin that aren't necessarily
look or feel like bitcoin that are down
a lot more than bitcoin yeah one thing i
would say is just think about the assets
that you own what equities you own uh
any cryptocurrencies you own and think
about look if this asset went down by 50
which we've seen bitcoin go 50 80 70
down if this asset went down by 50 would
i buy more or would i sell it out of
fear right and i think if you're gonna
sell it out of fear those are the ones
that you have to really think about and
be like do i want to be in this asset
because i obviously don't have that high
conviction of hey this will be long term
so if you're in amazon amazon is down 40
50 60 this year alone it's do i really
believe in amazon this if you do this is
the time to double down this is the time
to kind of load up on more stock like a
bunch of the ceos are doing when they're
doing corporate buybacks
that's exactly the point right the same
investing principles uh everyone makes
fun of of warren buffett and people like
that who maybe not don't understand
technology to the aspect that they
should today from an investment
perspective but their same principles
apply which is just dollar cost
averaging over a long time period into a
good business or a good company or a
good technology that you believe will
appreciate in value and become more
important and gain more users and more
market share for a long period of time
and don't do it with money that you need
immediately right because these are the
opportunities now where bitcoin drops
thirty five percent you're at eight
forty percent year-to-date and not only
maybe you don't have capital to go buy
more at a cheaper rate and dollar cost
average and take advantage of that but
some people need to pull capital out
because they over allocated themselves
and now they don't have the ability to
do that and they're selling at losses
right it's just a bad situation
and you need to be mindful of that
because whether it's a bull or bear
market those same principles apply for
100 plus years now of hey make sure
you're doing it right from an investment
perspective allocate correctly and then
just watch the uh the appreciation if
you pick the right asset and i think
that applies to bitcoin but it also
applies to broader markets in general
the risk you run is when you pick the
wrong asset right when you take
advantage of a market tailwind and
everyone running into crypto assets and
you pick these small cap assets that can
appreciate very quickly and rapidly and
you're looking for free money like
that's just not how it works investing
is not that easy and uh the asset is
obviously the most important part but
the principles probably follow along
along that quickly